foreign
[Music]
welcome back to True News and today's
top story is Dylan Dennis uh going after
Logan Paul's fiancee in an attempt to
get inside the head of Logan ahead of
the big fight coming up at Misfits I'll
get people like it when someone's
talking about Logan Paul all right
the guy is incredibly successful and
he's just got the happiest moment of his
life he's getting engaged he's getting
married it was dream girl life couldn't
be going battle for him right now he's
killing it in the WWE and of course us
being the internet whenever someone's
doing well will love to see them fall
don't we will love it let's just ruin
his life
sorry that was uh
unresolved trauma um we'll move on from
that so obviously I understand the
reason people want Logan to be in pain
but this girl ain't done nothing to any
of you yeah she's pretty she can handle
it she's got a big diamond ring her
happiness that is not fair in the fight
game almost anything goes but there's a
warrior code in the words of Chris
Eubank the Warrior's code you can say
whatever you want about each other but
you leave the families out of it and
this woman is now going to be his wife
but I don't think Dylan sees this as a
big deal in crossing the line because
he's just an online Troll and it's fair
game and who's his best friend Conor
McGregor he was doing this to dust
Emporia your wife see me DMS no one else
talks like that in the fight game and
the reality is he probably won't even
fight anywhere the last time KSI had a
fight lined up with him for a lot of
money he bottled it I just hope he's at
least got the balls to do what he didn't
do with KSI which is actually getting
the ring because this is your
last chance so to go further into the
details of what is going on here Logan
Paul obviously got engaged to his
beautiful fiance had this lovely
engagement video come out and then Dylan
Dallas somehow has gone deep into the
back catalog of This Woman's dating
history to insinuate that everyone who
she's ever had a photograph taken with
every man was once in a romantic
relationship with her which is obviously
ridiculous but the internet never lets
the truth get in the way of hammering
someone and now it's being put across as
if this girl is dated every single
celebrity in Hollywood which is
obviously not true but some of the
pictures are obviously of her kissing
guys and whatever else and it must be
really hard on her because it's like
welcome to being a YouTuber's wife like
even if you've not done anything that
people dislike Logan for will attack you
anyway people are clearly wanting them
to break up they're wanting to pay all
the pressure on they're wanting to ruin
what they've got I hope that this
creates some sort of mentality where
they stick together and don't let it
bother them because everyone pointing
the finger acting like oh Logan Paul's
fiance used to have she's have
boyfriends you know
oh yeah Leonardo DiCaprio like
it's like do you know I mean at least if
someone's been there before it's been an
Oscar winner right Kevin who works at
the swimming pool down the road blowing
out of your last mate and you're
pointing and laughing at Logan Paul I'm
sorry this ain't the same every woman
you meet in London's had 20 to 40 Dixon
or before you get there if you think
you're discovering something you're not
this ain't the moon landing you're
planting your flag on something that's
been well and truly planted before and
by flag I mean penis
I just feel bad for this girl like what
has she done do you know what I mean but
everyone apparently now talking I'm
joking I'm joking all right on two I
show speed or is now known as I showed
Dick the popular streamer who is often
compared to a young KSI uh because of
his extreme energy and um dick he must
have done something good on his stream
because he decides to his dick out
and throw it in the face of what is it
actually predominantly young audience I
always wondered like what is the new
generation of talented young YouTubers
gonna show us their dick apparently now
this guy just to be clear sets Fireworks
off in his house to get views like
everything he does is very loud and ah
please look at me hey give me attention
like if he'll set a firework off in his
house do you really think he won't
deliberately flash his dick this was
absolutely choreographed no I'm not
seeing I want this guy to get canceled
I'm not one of that Brigade but
someone needs to have a chat when you
start doing these things and more and
more extreme things to try and get views
where does it end he should have a chat
with people like the ogs the Logan
Paul's the care size because this ain't
the way me you're not gonna look back on
this when you're 56 years old and go God
I'm telling me look great didn't it
that's not gonna happen what time was it
11 A.M no one wants to see your at
11AM for Christ's sakes land put it away
that being said people love this guy and
he can do a lot of good with that energy
and I'm pretty sure you can do better
than wafting your dick around it's my
take just my take no he's got a lot of
fans who probably won't like what I've
got to say and unfortunately I don't
give a if anything I'll probably
not being tough enough on this lad but
I'm trying to give him the benefit of
the dog because he is young and stupid
and hopefully in time he'll wake up and
go is that really the content like if I
did this at Eldon Square I would be
locked up just to be clear I would never
do that you'd have to worry about
that getting wafted around
Elden Square not unless Newcastle win
the league speaking of getting dicks in
your face Mia Khalifa has some advice
for you lot okay so this video starts
with Mia uh being a bit triggered by
someone laughing at the fact that she'd
been divorced before oh we're comparing
stats baby girl doesn't know that I am
Tom Brady at this game now just to be
clear being good at marriage doesn't
mean I got married the most amount of
times this is a terrible way to look at
it married at 18 divorced at 21. second
marriage married at 25 divorced at 28.
third engagement engaged at 29 ended it
at 30 but I kept the ring I'm still
keeping Tom Brady on his toes
the only thing she knows about Tom Brady
and big guys like the NFL guys is the
big who ran a train on her
all over the Internet Tom Brady doesn't
want to know you we are not stuck with
these people marriage is not a
sanctimonious thing it is it is
paperwork it's something it's it's it's
a commitment you make to someone but if
you feel like
you're not getting anything from that
commitment and you're trying you gotta
go you gotta go you have to go if
there's ever a way to not live your life
it's from a woman who got down
all over the internet then proceeded to
cry about it while continuing to use
that name that she gave herself in the
industry make herself a victim but still
keep making money off of what she did
this woman is a walking contradiction
she does not know whether she's coming
or going I've seen her come a few times
and let's not forget the men that you
attract when you have previously had a
train run on you are not the kind of
guys who are probably gonna be good at
long-term commitment the first time they
ever seen you was getting nutted on when
I watch a woman get nutted on on the
internet I don't think of the time I'm
gonna pull the and I'll kiss the bride
that's not on my mind imagine bringing
this home to your mother are you crazy
bringing her home to your mother she
can't cook she has this thing of like oh
marriage doesn't mean anything I you
know I I agree I disagree that's the
same attitude that she took towards her
adult entertainment industry oh I can
just do this it won't mean anything then
I thought everyone thinks I'm a now
why do you think that is consequences
love anyone who's watching this any man
this is why you don't go near this woman
she values nothing and then complains
later when it it is invaluable what
she's trying to do is turn her own
insecurities here into a positive of oh
I'm Tom Brady I'm empowered because I've
been engaged so many times you've never
completed it the goal is to stay married
to be in a healthy loving relationship
you can't do that probably because
you're so up and that's fine
you're allowed to be up but what
you shouldn't be doing is then telling
your up ideologies to a bunch of
young impressionable women out there who
listen to you and think you may have the
answer because if there's anyone you
shouldn't be modeling your life on it's
her I know it's difficult to fill out
paperwork and to make appointments and
to do all of these things imagine
looking at her in in the eyes after what
you've seen her get up there when going
in sickness and health till death do us
part who the was stupid enough to
say that to her I've seen her like this
man go and skiing you're trying to wipe
that up you crazy bastard to be
fair you would though wouldn't you just
for one night just
soon it was like more than anything
yeah you're right I wouldn't
yes the corpse of Michael Jackson is
sleeping peacefully known he got away
with it but apparently maybe not uh
because we are trying to do the Jimmy
Savile thing and uh get him after all of
the kitties have been fiddled
I know he made some good music but this
isn't a reason to just ignore the fact
that what 10 kids came forward and one
of them was paid like 20 30 million to
not go to trial apparently there is
smoke without fire Michael would never
go and do a thing like that meanwhile
right you get him being interviewed
Michael
do you think it's normal for a 45 year
old man asleep with an eight-year-old
boy yes what 45 year old man does that I
know he made Thriller I like the
moonwalk Billie Jean was a classic the
man's a goddamn child bloody yeah one of
them though had cancer as well at the
time and he was saying Michael Jackson
as like a Make-a-Wish thing but yeah
that was what wasn't what he wished for
Jesus it's all just a big lie I don't
buy oh Michael Jackson didn't have a
childhood and he just wanted to rehab a
childhood how many other men would get
away with that and for everyone out
there saying Why didn't it come forward
then do you know how hard it is to come
forward against the biggest pop star in
the world when you're a 10 year old kid
are you joking so let me get this
straight Nutley Portman the star of Star
Wars beautiful woman got cheated on by
this Giza Benjamin millipede that's not
the best name is it millipede
it helped me we really are the dumbest
song with men we are the dumbest people
alive oh my God is that who we cheated
on her with Jesus it gets worse no
offense like the bloody hell what the
have you done Benjamin was spotted
out and about with a French climate
activist oh God
now claim it activist
look at those oh is she gonna join the
just stop oil and all that as well
as oh he's a New York ballet dancer
that explains a dick in other news
Little T here was reported dead recently
turns out she's alive so nobody really
cared so for those I don't know she was
a child on social media who used to flex
her money and basically I think her
mother was some sort of like estate
agent who'd like show Posh houses off to
people and she used to go there with her
mother and record videos as if it was
all hers that was the story allegedly
then she disappeared from social media
and clearly whoever the was looking
after I was doing a terrible job so
since then a mother spoken now because
apparently they're in a custody battle
in order to get little to to return to
the internet because in 2018 her dad got
a court order to get her to stop making
online content and return to Vancouver
where she was apparently born the dad is
trying to do the good thing and keep
this girl off the internet and raise her
into a normal human being her mother
obviously has different ideas on the Kim
K thing where her mother basically was
like yeah sure make a sex tape get
is exactly why we need dads oh deadbeat
dads sometimes dads are in handy Jesus
Christ in an interview back in 2018 Lil
taya's father Christopher had said
everyone else involved in this situation
is motivated by money and the
possibility of making money off my
daughter I am not fighting about money
I'm fighting for my daughter for her
happiness for her future
but we don't need Duds do we no no no
they're just dead beats they're just
dead beats that don't care what else has
been happening some woman's a dick that
they're massive tits aren't we all ah
TLC this is the gift that keeps on
giving this channel I tell you and here
is Foxy 45 years old I'm assuming that's
not her real name
do you know when a woman has a side
profile like that and her lips are so
far out you could sit a pint of beer on
them that's not the look ladies I'm
saying this with love stop doing this to
yourselves no man walks past the ingots
look at the lips on that it doesn't
happen we don't do it and I know you're
like well I'm doing it for me are you
really is your goal really to make
yourself look repulsive because if you
if that's the goal then cut crack on you
know what I mean oh my God it fits
I didn't know they were that big
really I'm speechless yeah like I'm
supposed to be giving you guys a
commentary I got nothing I don't know
what the to say
they passed her belly button she ain't
even seen a belly button in years I like
extra large boobs
they'll acceptance you know what I mean
like they're like big off air
balloons forced inside a human body the
skin what how is that skin even
functioning to wrap around this
bullet oh Jesus
she's happy guarantee she's got a
normally fans Gara and teed some of you
that are probably subscribed you
filthy yeah it totally works no way
she's got the Austin as well it's this
is this is oh
she's probably like I'm 45 new one wants
to shaggers let's just go Mendel if it's
on tap and it fits on bottom yeah you've
stretched it over not it doesn't fit
nothing about this says that fits
imagine you threw that bra on drakestage
Jesus
it's a perfect fit
do you know do you not right this is a
cycle yeah I think that's enough for one
week yep yep okay uh I appreciate
everyone who's supporting this show
don't forget to hit that like button let
us know what you thought of all the
topics in the comments below especially
that last one and I'll see is on the
next one
thank you
foreign
[Music]